selamat datang kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengkomputeran Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah pengarah teknikal pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini ialah pelajaran nombor 14 siri ini dan ia merupakan pelajaran kedua unit keempat yang berkaitan dengan pembetulan ralat Kuantum
dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita melihat pertama kali pembetulan ralat kuantum termasuk kod Shore sembilan Qubit yang menetapkan bahawa
pembetulan ralat kuantum mungkin secara teori kita juga bincangkan pendigitalan Ralat yang membolehkan kita
membetulkan ralat kuantum sewenang-wenang pada qubit dengan secara berkesan mengunjurkannya ke atas flip bit dan flip fasa
dalam pelajaran ini kita akan bincangkan formalisme penstabil yang merupakan alat matematik yang mana kita boleh
menentukan dan menganalisis kelas luas kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang dikenali sebagai kod penstabil ini termasuk kod Shore 9 Qubit
bersama banyak contoh lain termasuk kod yang berkemungkinan lebih sesuai untuk dunia sebenar peranti Pengkomputeran Kuantum
berbanding kod shore tidak setiap kod pembetulan ralat kuantum adalah kod penstabil tetapi banyak yang merupakan
termasuk setiap contoh yang akan kita lihat dalam siri ini sudah tentu ada kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang menarik dan berpotensi berguna
yang bukan kod penstabil tetapi ia cenderung lebih rumit dan dalam apa jua keadaan tidak ada
keraguan bahawa formalisme penstabil adalah Batu Asas dalam asas pembetulan ralat kuantum dan kita akan
bergantung kepadanya dengan banyak untuk selebihnya unit berikut ialah gambaran ringkas pelajaran kita akan mulakan dengan perbincangan singkat
tentang matriks Pauli dan hasil darab tensor matriks Pauli yang boleh mewakili kedua-dua operasi pada qubit serta
pengukuran qubit seperti yang akan saya terangkan dan dalam konteks ini kita selalu merujuknya sebagai boleh ukur kita kemudian akan kembali dan melihat
pandangan kedua pada kod pengulangan dan kita akan lihat cara kita boleh menerangkannya melalui operasi Pauli dan boleh ukur dan itu akan memaklumkan
dan membawa kepada perbincangan umum tentang kod penstabil termasuk beberapa contoh sifat asas penstabil
kod dan cara kita boleh melaksanakan tugas asas pengekodan mengesan ralat dan membetulkan ralat tersebut
kita akan mulakan pelajaran dengan perbincangan ringkas tentang operasi Pauli terutamanya untuk menetapkan peringkat untuk
formalisme penstabil tetapi juga untuk memerhatikan beberapa fakta utama dan menetapkan beberapa terminologi asas pertama inilah matriks Pauli
termasuk Matriks identiti 2x2 serta tiga matriks Pauli bukan identiti yang akan kita tandakan dengan
huruf besar X X Y dan Z sepanjang selebihnya siri ini keempat-empat matriks ini adalah kedua-dua unitari dan hermitian dan kita boleh
mengenal pasti ia dengan operasi pada qubit termasuk operasi yang mungkin kita pilih untuk dilakukan serta ralat seperti yang
kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya matriks Pauli bukan identiti X Y dan Z anti-tukar ganti dengan satu sama lain
bermaksud XY adalah sama dengan -1 * YX XZ adalah sama dengan negatif ZX dan YZ adalah sama
dengan negatif z y dan korang boleh mudah semak hubungan ini dengan melakukan pendaraban hubungan anti-tukar ganti ini
adalah sangat mudah tetapi ia sangat penting dalam formalisme penstabil dan di tempat lain dan khususnya
seperti yang akan kita lihat tanda tolak yang muncul apabila kita menukar susunan dua matriks Pauli bukan identiti yang berbeza dalam produk sepadan tepat dengan
pengesanan ralat dalam formalisme penstabil kita juga mempunyai peraturan pendaraban yang disenaraikan di sini setiap
matriks Pauli adalah songsangnya sendiri yang konsisten dengan fakta bahawa ia kedua-duanya unitari dan hermitian dan kalau korang darab mana-mana dua yang berbeza bukan identiti
matriks Pauli bersama korang akan sentiasa mendapat tambah atau tolak I kali matriks Pauli bukan identiti yang tinggal
khususnya sehingga fasa global Y bersamaan dengan X kali Z yang menjelaskan fokus kita pada ralat x dan z dalam
pembetulan ralat kuantum X mewakili flip bit Z mewakili flip fasa dan jadi sehingga fasa global y mewakili
kedua-dua ralat ini berlaku pada Qubit yang sama keempat-empat matriks ini semua mewakili
operasi atau ralat atau ketiadaan ralat pada satu Qubit tetapi ia sering mudah untuk tensor mereka bersama
untuk melakukan operasi atau ralat pada berbilang qubit sebagai titik terminologi bila-bila masa kita merujuk kepada operasi Pauli N Qubit
kita maksudkan hasil darab tensor mana-mana n matriks Pauli seperti contoh yang ditunjukkan
di sini adalah juga biasa untuk guna istilah operasi Pauli apabila ada fasa global tetapi untuk memastikan segala-galanya semudah mungkin
saya akan guna istilah operasi Pauli untuk bermaksud hanya hasil darab tensor matriks Pauli berat operasi Pauli qubit n
hanyalah bilangan matriks Pauli bukan identiti dalam hasil darab tensor contohnya hasil darab tensor n kali ganda
Matriks identiti 2 x dua dengan dirinya sendiri adalah operasi Pauli berat sifar hasil darab tensor dua matriks Pauli x
dan banyak matriks identiti mempunyai berat dua dan seterusnya secara intuitif berat operasi Pauli N
Qubit adalah bilangan qubit yang ia bertindak secara bukan remeh dan adalah tipikal bahawa kod pembetulan ralat kuantum adalah
direka supaya ia boleh mengesan dan membetulkan ralat yang diwakili oleh operasi Pauli sehingga berat tertentu kita boleh
memikirkan tentang operasi Pauli dalam pelbagai cara termasuk sebagai operasi yang dilakukan dengan sengaja oleh gate Kuantum serta
ralat dan kita juga akan lihat tidak lama lagi bahawa operasi Pauli boleh menerangkan pengukuran kadang-kadang ia juga berguna
untuk memikirkan tentang operasi Pauli sebagai penjana set tertentu dalam erti kata aljabar yang mungkin korang kenali
kalau korang biasa dengan teori kumpulan kalau korang tidak biasa dengan Teori Kumpulan itu okay ia tidak benar-benar penting
untuk pelajaran ini tetapi kalau korang berminat untuk mengkaji pembetulan ralat kuantum dengan lebih mendalam korang mungkin mendapati bahawa beberapa
teori kumpulan asas sangat membantu untuk melakukan itu bagaimanapun jom kita andaikan bahawa P1 hingga PR adalah operasi Pauli N Qubit
jadi P1 adalah operasi Pauli qubit n P2 adalah operasi Pauli qubit n dan seterusnya apabila kita merujuk kepada set yang dijana oleh
P1 hingga p r apa yang kita maksudkan ialah set semua matriks yang boleh kita peroleh dengan mendarabkan matriks ini bersama dalam
apa jua kombinasi dan dalam apa jua susunan yang kita pilih mengambil setiap satu sebanyak kali yang kita suka kita akan lihat beberapa contoh dalam sebentar
lagi tetapi pertama izinkan saya menyebut notasi yang kita guna untuk menandakan set ini set yang dijana oleh P1 hingga PR dan
ia adalah P1 hingga PR yang dipisahkan oleh koma di dalam kurungan bersudut ia memang kelihatan seperti kita mudah keliru
notasi ini dengan notasi langsung tetapi itu biasanya tidak berlaku dan ini adalah notasi tradisional dalam teori
Kumpulan inilah contoh set yang dijana oleh X Y dan Z jadi n adalah sama dengan satu dalam contoh ini kerana tidak ada
hasil darab tensor dan kita mengambil ketiga-tiga matriks Pauli bukan identiti sebagai penjana rupanya ada
16 matriks yang boleh dijana dengan membentuk produk yang merangkumi tiga matriks ini dan korang boleh menganalisanya
melalui peraturan pendaraban yang kita lihat sebelumnya khususnya kita sudah tentu boleh mendapatkan X Y dan Z serta identiti
dan sebenarnya kita juga boleh mendapatkan mana-mana empat matriks ini kali I 1 atau negatif I dan itulah
WEBVTT
sahaja set ini biasanya dikenali sebagai kumpulan Pauli kita juga boleh pertimbangkan set
yang dijana oleh hanya x dan z dan kita berakhir mendapat separuh daripada kumpulan Pauli dalam kes ini
dan satu contoh terakhir sekurang-kurangnya buat masa ini kita boleh pertimbangkan set yang dijana oleh X tensor x dan z tensor Z jadi n adalah sama dengan
dua dalam kes ini dan kita berakhir mendapat hanya empat elemen kali ini kerana X tensor x dan z tensor Z
bertukar ganti dengan satu sama lain matriks Pauli dan operasi Pauli N Qubit secara lebih umum menerangkan
operasi unitari sama ada ia ralat atau ia disengajakan tetapi ia juga menerangkan
pengukuran untuk lebih tepat bermula dengan hanya tiga matriks Pauli bukan identiti kita boleh mengaitkan setiap matriks ini
dengan pengukuran unjuran yang ditakrifkan dari segi nilai eigen dan vektor eigennya dan di sini pada skrin kita
mempunyai penguraian spektrum matriks-matriks ini yang akan membantu menjelaskan ini pada dasarnya apabila kita merujuk kepada pengukuran X
pengukuran y atau pengukuran z kita maksudkan pengukuran unjuran yang ditakrifkan oleh unjuran
ke atas ruang eigen matriks ini dan lazimnya kita memikirkan nilai eigen sebagai hasil pengukuran yang sepadan
contohnya pengukuran X adalah pengukuran berkenaan dengan asas tambah
tolak qubit atau secara alternatif kita boleh menerangkannya dengan set yang mengandungi unjuran Kat plus Bra tambah dan K
tolak bra tolak pengukuran z sebaliknya tidak lebih daripada pengukuran asas standard
walaupun seperti yang saya katakan kita kadang-kadang mengenal pasti nilai eigen dengan hasil pengukuran dan kalau kita lakukan
itu maka hasilnya adalah tambah dan tolak satu berbanding 0 dan satu masing-masing kita sebenarnya boleh melakukan sesuatu
di sepanjang garisan ini untuk matriks hermitian sewenang-wenang dan istilah boleh ukur biasa digunakan dalam situasi ini untuk Pauli
matriks dan operasi Pauli qubit n secara lebih umum kita boleh melakukan pengukuran sedemikian secara tidak merosakkan menggunakan
anggaran fasa dan hanya untuk memastikan diagram ini jelas di sini kita melakukan pengukuran secara tidak merosakkan pada
Qubit atas sedangkan qubit bawah sentiasa dimulakan kepada keadaan tambah atau dengan kata lain Hadamard digunakan kepada
keadaan sifar kerana itulah cara anggaran fasa berfungsi perhatikan bahawa kerana nilai I
hanya tambah satu dan tolak satu dalam kes ini kita hanya perlukan satu Qubit kawalan yang merupakan qubit bawah dalam
diagram ini lebih daripada itu hanya akan membazir kerana hanya ada satu bit ketepatan yang perlu dibimbangkan nilai ion
adalah sama ada tambah satu atau tolak satu dan pengukuran sudah sempurna seperti ini hasil pengukuran ini by the way
bermaksud pengukuran asas standard dalam circuit itu akan menjadi sifar untuk hasil nilai eigen tambah satu
yang sepadan dengan keadaan tambah dalam kes boleh ukur X dan hasilnya adalah satu untuk nilai ion tolak satu
atau keadaan tolak dalam kes ini semua yang baru saya katakan meluas secara semula jadi kepada operasi Pauli qubit n
dengan syarat kita ingat bahawa apabila kita memikirkan tentang boleh ukur kita bercakap tentang mengukur nilai eigen
bukan mengukur berkenaan dengan asas vektor eigen contohnya pertimbangkan dua
operasi Pauli Qubit Z tensor Z sekali lagi ada dua nilai eigen tambah satu dan tolak satu jadi
pengukuran itu diterangkan oleh dua unjuran perhatikan khususnya bahawa pengukuran yang kita kaitkan dengan
boleh ukur ini tidak sama dengan mengukur kedua-dua qubit dengan pengukuran z atau dengan kata lain pengukuran asas standard tetapi sebaliknya ia adalah dua
hasil pengukuran unjuran di mana unjuran adalah ke ruang yang dibentangkan oleh semua vektor IG yang sepadan dengan
setiap dua nilai eigen tambah satu dan tolak satu satu lagi cara memikirkan tentang ini ialah nilai eigen dari tensor
produk adalah produk nilai IG matriks individu yang kita ambil hasil darab tensor dan
kerana negatif 1 * negatif 1 adalah sama dengan positif 1 * positif 1 contohnya pengukuran ini tidak
membezakan antara 0 0 dan 1 satu jadi kalau kita mengukur katakan keadaan Bell lima tambah dengan pengukuran
yang diterangkan oleh boleh ukur ini kita akan pasti mendapat hasil yang sepadan dengan I Value Tambah Satu
dan keadaan tidak akan berubah berbanding runtuh ke 0 0 atau 1 satu yang akan berlaku kalau kita
melakukan pengukuran asas standard pada dua qubit jadi pengukuran z tensor z bukanlah
perkara yang sama dengan melakukan dua pengukuran Z secara bebas tetapi kita sebenarnya boleh melakukan pengukuran seperti ini menggunakan anggaran
fasa tepat dengan cara yang sama seperti sebelumnya menggunakan satu Qubit kawalan seperti yang ditunjukkan dalam diagram circuit yang
mengeneralisasikan kepada mana-mana operasi Pauli qubit n sebagai ganti Z tensor Z apabila kita mempunyai hanya matriks Z Pauli by the way
kita boleh mempermudah circuit seperti ini dan apa yang ini mendedahkan yang juga jelas dari unjuran yang mentakrifkan
pengukuran ialah melakukan pengukuran z tensor Z pada dua qubit bersamaan dengan mengukur pariti mereka
berfikir dari segi asas standard dan ini mengeneralisasikan kepada hasil darab tensor sebarang bilangan Pauli Z
matriks seterusnya kita akan melihat pandangan kedua pada kod pengulangan tiga-bit kali ini mengungkapkannya dari segi operasi Pauli
ini akan menjadi contoh pertama kita yang agak mudah tentang kod penstabil dan kita akan bincangkan cara untuk mengeneralisasikan
tanggapan ini tidak lama lagi tetapi adalah berguna untuk melihat cara ia berfungsi dalam kes mudah ini pertama ingat bahawa apabila kita guna
kod pengulangan 3-bit kepada qubit kita mengekod keadaan Qubit yang diberikan Alpha 0 tambah beta 1 sebagai Alpha 0000 0 tambah beta 11 1 1
dan kita akan berikan pengekodan tiga Qubit ini nama Sai untuk kemudahan jadi mengikut definisi s adalah pengekodan tiga Qubit yang sah
bagi keadaan qubit tetapi kalau kita ingin menyemak ini cukup untuk menyemak bahawa dua persamaan berikut adalah benar
persamaan pertama menyatakan bahawa menggunakan operasi Z kepada dua qubit paling kiri s tidak melakukan apa-apa kepada S yang bermaksud bahawa
SII adalah vektor eigen Z tensor Z tensor Identiti atau hanya identiti ZZ secara ringkas dengan nilai ion satu dan yang kedua
persamaan adalah serupa kecuali operasi Z digunakan kepada dua qubit paling kanan ideanya ialah kalau kita fikir tentang S
sebagai kombinasi linear keadaan asas standard maka persamaan pertama membayangkan bahawa kita hanya boleh mempunyai pekali bukan sifar untuk keadaan asas standard
di mana dua bit paling kiri mempunyai pariti genap atau bersamaan sama dan persamaan kedua membayangkan bahawa kita hanya boleh
mempunyai pekali bukan sifar untuk keadaan asas standard yang mana dua bit paling kanan mempunyai pariti genap satu lagi cara untuk memikirkan tentang ini
ialah melihat dua operasi Pauli ini sebagai boleh ukur dan kalau kita mengukur dua boleh ukur ini menggunakan
circuit ringkas yang saya sebutkan sebentar tadi maka kita akan pasti mendapat hasil pengukuran yang sepadan dengan nilai eigen tambah satu
kerana s adalah Vektor eigen kedua-dua boleh ukur dengan nilai eigen satu tetapi versi ringkas gabungan ini
WEBVTT
circuit untuk mengukur boleh ukur secara bebas tidak lain daripada circuit semak pariti kita untuk 3-bit
kod pengulangan dan jadi kita lihat bahawa dua persamaan kita bersama bersamaan dengan circuit semak pariti mengeluarkan 0 0
yang merupakan sindrom yang menunjukkan bahawa tiada ralat dikesan operasi Pauli tiga Qubit
identiti ZZ dan identiti ZZ dipanggil penjana penstabil untuk kod ini dan penstabil kod adalah set
yang dijana oleh penjana penstabil set ini penstabil adalah objek matematik yang sangat penting
yang dikaitkan dengan kod ini dan kita akan bincangkan lebih lanjut peranan yang dimainkannya semasa pelajaran berlanjutan buat masa ini
saya hanya akan jelaskan bahawa kita boleh membuat pilihan yang berbeza untuk penjana contohnya kita boleh memilih Z identiti Z sebagai ganti sama ada
penjana yang kita pilih dan kod dan penstabil akan sama persis seterusnya kita akan pertimbangkan pengesanan flip bit
untuk kod pengulangan tiga-bit dengan fokus pada interaksi dan hubungan di antara operasi Pauli
yang terlibat iaitu penjana penstabil dan ralat itu sendiri andaikan kita telah mengekod
qubit menggunakan kod pengulangan tiga-bit dan ralat flip bit berlaku pada Qubit paling kiri ini menyebabkan keadaan sisi kita menjadi
diubah mengikut tindakan operasi X atau ralat X pada Qubit paling kiri seperti yang sudah kita tahu kita boleh mengesan
ralat ini dengan melakukan semakan pariti untuk kod pengulangan tiga-bit atau bersamaan kita boleh mengukur
pengekodan secara tidak merosakkan dengan memperlakukan penjana penstabil sebagai boleh ukur jom kita mulakan dengan yang pertama
penjana penstabil dan lihat apa yang berlaku keadaan kita telah dipengaruhi oleh ralat X dan kita ingin faham
bagaimana pengukuran penjana penstabil sebagai boleh ukur dipengaruhi oleh ralat ini x dan z anti-tukar ganti sedangkan
semua perkara bertukar ganti dengan matriks identiti dan jadi ia mengikut bahawa identiti ZZ anti-tukar ganti dengan X identiti
identiti jadi kita mendapat tanda tolak apabila susunan ditukar dan kita juga tahu bahawa identiti ZZ tidak melakukan apa-apa kepada S
kerana s adalah pengekodan sah qubit dan pengekodan sah sentiasa merupakan vektor eigen tambah satu kedua-dua penstabil
penjana yang meninggalkan kita dengan X identiti identiti negatif yang digunakan kepada S dan oleh itu X identiti identiti yang digunakan kepada
S adalah Vektor eigen identiti ZZ dengan nilai eigen negatif satu kita juga boleh melakukan sesuatu yang serupa
dengan penjana penstabil kedua tetapi kali ini ralat bertukar ganti dengan penjana penstabil dan jadi
Keadaan yang Rosak kita sekali lagi adalah vektor igon penjana penstabil tetapi kali ini nilai eigen adalah positif
satu jadi Keadaan yang Rosak kita adalah Vektor IG kedua-dua penjana penstabil dan sama ada nilai eigen adalah tambah satu atau
tolak satu ditentukan oleh sama ada ralat bertukar ganti atau anti-tukar ganti dengan setiap penjana penstabil untuk yang pertama
ralat dan penjana penstabil anti-tukar ganti dan untuk yang kedua ia bertukar ganti dan ia akan sentiasa menjadi satu atau yang lain kerana mana-mana dua
operasi Pauli sama ada bertukar ganti atau anti-tukar ganti sementara itu keadaan sebenar sisi tidak benar-benar memainkan peranan penting
di sini kecuali untuk fakta bahawa penjana penstabil bertindak secara remeh pada keadaan ini jadi apabila kita memikirkan tentang
pengesanan Ralat kita benar-benar tidak perlu membimbangkan diri kita dengan keadaan yang dikodkan secara khusus semua yang penting ialah sama ada ralat bertukar ganti atau anti-tukar
ganti dengan setiap penjana penstabil jadi jom kita buat jadual yang mempunyai satu baris untuk setiap penjana penstabil
dan satu lajur untuk setiap ralat di sini saya hanya menyertakan ralat yang sepadan dengan satu flip bit serta
tiada ralat sama sekali yang ditunjukkan oleh identiti yang ditensor dengan dirinya sendiri tiga kali kita boleh menambah lebih banyak lajur untuk ralat lain kalau kita mahu
tetapi buat masa ini kita akan fokus pada ralat ini sahaja entri dalam jadual adalah sama ada tambah satu atau tolak satu bergantung kepada
sama ada ralat dan penjana penstabil bertukar ganti atau anti-tukar ganti jadi untuk setiap ralat dalam jadual kita boleh lihat
lajur yang sepadan untuk melihat bagaimana ralat itu akan mengubah mana-mana pengekodan yang diberikan kepada vektor eigen tambah satu atau tolak satu
setiap penjana penstabil lajur-lajur ini sepadan tepat dengan sindrom yang akan kita peroleh daripada
semakan pariti yang bersamaan dengan pengukuran tidak merosakkan penjana penstabil sebagai
boleh ukur sudah tentu entri dalam jadual ini adalah tambah satu dan tolak satu berbanding sifar dan satu masing-masing
dan kalau korang suka korang boleh fikir tentang sindrom sebagai rentetan binari yang sepadan berbanding Lajur tambah satu dan tolak satu tetapi ada
perkaitannya secara langsung dan hanya untuk memastikan kaitan antara sindrom dan nilai eigen lebih jelas dan langsung
saya akan merujuk kepada vektor tambah satu dan tolak satu ini sebagai sindrom seperti sebelumnya sindrom memberitahu
kita sesuatu tentang apa jua ralat yang berlaku dan khususnya kalau kita tahu bahawa salah satu daripada empat kemungkinan ralat ini
berlaku sindrom menunjukkan kepada kita yang mana satu ia dan kita boleh membetulkannya dengan menggunakan ralat itu semula kalau kita
pilih seterusnya saya akan berkata hanya sedikit lebih tentang sindrom dan khususnya kita akan melihat lebih dekat pada
aspek aljabar mereka pengekodan kita adalah keadaan tiga Qubit jadi ia adalah vektor unit dalam
ruang vektor kompleks lapan dimensi dan apa yang empat kemungkinan sindrom lakukan ialah menghiris ruang lapan dimensi ini
kepada empat subruang dua dimensi bermaksud bahawa vektor dalam mana-mana satu subruang ini akan sentiasa memberi kita yang sama
sindrom secara lebih terperinci diagram ini menggambarkan cara ruang lapan dimensi dibahagikan
setiap penjana penstabil memisahkan ruang kepada dua subruang dimensi sama iaitu ruang tambah satu
vektor IG dan ruang tolak satu I vektor contohnya vektor tambah satu identiti ZZ adalah kombinasi linear
keadaan asas standard yang mana dua bit paling kiri mempunyai pariti genap dan vektor eigen tolak satu adalah kombinasi linear
keadaan asas standard yang mana dua bit paling kiri mempunyai pariti ganjil dan situasinya adalah serupa untuk
penjana penstabil yang lain kecuali bahawa ia adalah dua bit paling kanan berbanding dua bit paling kiri jadi empat subruang ini mudah untuk
diterangkan dalam kes ini kerana ini adalah kod yang sangat mudah khususnya Subruang
yang sepadan dengan sindrom tambah satu +1 adalah ruang yang dibentangkan oleh C 000000 dan K 111 yang merupakan ruang pengekodan yang sah
dan itu dipanggil ruang kod dan secara umum ruang dibentangkan oleh keadaan asas standard
yang ditunjukkan dalam petak yang sepadan walaupun ia tidak semestinya sejelas atau semudah untuk melihat sindrom
juga mengasingkan semua operasi Pauli tiga Qubit yang mewakili kemungkinan ralat Pauli yang boleh berlaku kepada empat koleksi saiz sama
bergantung kepada sindrom mana yang akan disebabkan oleh ralat tersebut contohnya mana-mana operasi Pauli
yang bertukar ganti dengan kedua-dua penjana penstabil menghasilkan sindrom plus1 plus1 dan antara 64 kemungkinan tiga
operasi Pauli Qubit ada tepat 16 daripadanya dalam kategori ini termasuk tiga yang disebutkan pada skrin dan begitu juga untuk tiga yang lain
WEBVTT
sindrom itu tidak jelas tetapi ia benar dan sifat asas ini bahawa sindrom mengasingkan kedua-dua ruang keadaan
di mana pengekodan hidup dan semua kemungkinan polyer dalam ruang kepada kepingan saiz sama adalah sesuatu yang
benar secara umum untuk kod penstabil yang tidak lama lagi akan ditakrifkan dengan tepat walaupun ia kebanyakannya hanyalah sebagai catatan tambahan pada
ketika ini berbaloi untuk menyebut bahawa operasi Pauli yang bertukar ganti dengan kedua-dua penjana penstabil atau bersamaan
operasi Pauli yang menghasilkan sindrom plus1 +1 tetapi tidak sendirinya berkadar dengan elemen penstabil rupanya berkelakuan seperti
operasi Pauli satu Qubit pada Qubit Logik yang kita kodkan contohnya xxx bertukar ganti dengan
kedua-dua penjana penstabil tetapi ia tidak berkadar dengan mana-mana elemen penstabil dan memang jelas kalau korang
fikir tentang kod ini sebentar bahawa kesan yang dimiliki operasi ini pada pengekodan bersamaan dengan gate X pada
Qubit logik yang dikodkan dan sekali lagi ini adalah sesuatu yang mengeneralisasikan kepada semua kod penstabil sekarang sudah tiba masanya untuk menakrifkan penstabil
kod secara umum dan cara ia berfungsi ialah kita melakukan sesuatu yang benar-benar analogous dengan apa yang baru kita bincangkan untuk
kod pengulangan tiga-bit kecuali kita memilih penjana penstabil yang berbeza yang semua dirujuk sebagai P1
hingga PR untuk tujuan penjelasan ini penjana penstabil ini semua mestilah operasi Pauli qubit n
di mana n adalah bilangan qubit yang digunakan untuk pengekodan dan kita tidak boleh hanya memilih mana-mana set penjana penstabil ia
mesti memenuhi beberapa syarat asas pertama penjana penstabil SEMUA mesti bertukar ganti dengan satu
sama lain dalam kes kod pengulangan tiga-bit kita tidak ambil pusing untuk mengambil perhatian tentang ini tetapi adalah mudah untuk memerhatikan bahawa identiti ZZ dan identiti
ZZ sebenarnya bertukar ganti kerana Z bertukar ganti dengan dirinya sendiri dan semua perkara bertukar ganti dengan
identiti untuk kod penstabil dengan penjana penstabil yang lebih rumit sebaliknya termasuk kod di mana kita mempunyai
kedua-dua x dan Z yang muncul dalam penjana penstabil ini adalah syarat penting yang perlu
diperiksa satu cara untuk memikirkan keperluan syarat ini ialah kita akan memperlakukan penjana penstabil sebagai boleh ukur dan dengan memerlukan bahawa
ia semua bertukar ganti kita memastikan bahawa susunan pengukuran ini dilakukan tidak
penting kedua penjana penstabil mesti membentuk set penjana minimum yang dipanggil yang bermaksud jika kita membuang mana-mana
satu daripadanya kita akan mendapat penstabil yang lebih kecil dan satu cara untuk menyatakan ini secara matematik ditunjukkan di sini pada
skrin secara tegas syarat ini tidak benar-benar penting kepada cara kod penstabil berfungsi dalam erti kata operasional
dan kadang-kadang ia memang masuk akal untuk memikirkan set penjana bukan minimum seperti yang akan kita lihat dalam pelajaran seterusnya tetapi
untuk tujuan menganalisis kod penstabil dan menerangkan sifatnya kita akan mengandaikan bahawa syarat ini adalah
wujud pada dasarnya syarat ini menjamin bahawa setiap boleh ukur yang kita ukur untuk mendapatkan sindrom menambah
maklumat tentang kemungkinan ralat berbanding menjadi berlebihan dan memberi hasil yang mudah disimpulkan daripada penjana penstabil lain sebagai
boleh ukur dan akhirnya mestilah sekurang-kurangnya satu Vektor bukan sifar ditetapkan oleh semua
penjana penstabil dan itu rupanya bersamaan dengan memerlukan bahawa -1 kali identiti pada N qubit adalah
tidak terkandung dalam penstabil itu tidak jelas tetapi intinya ialah adalah mungkin untuk memilih set penjana minimum
operasi Pauli qubit n yang semua bertukar ganti dengan satu sama lain namun tiada Vektor secara serentak merupakan vektor eigen tambah satu
semua daripadanya dan kita tidak ingin membimbangkan diri kita dengan kemungkinan ini kerana kod di mana tidak ada pengekodan yang sah bukanlah
menarik jadi itulah keperluan pada penjana penstabil untuk kod penstabil dan kalau kita memang mempunyai set penjana yang
memenuhi syarat ini maka kita mempunyai kod penstabil yang sah dan kita boleh mempertimbangkan sifatnya ada banyak
kod penstabil yang berbeza dengan pelbagai sifat yang menjadikan ia menarik atau tidak tetapi ia semua memenuhi sifat asas tertentu
yang mengingatkan kita pada yang telah kita perhatikan untuk kod pengulangan tiga-bit
kita akan lihat beberapa contoh tidak lama lagi tetapi sebelum itu izinkan saya sebutkan bahawa apabila kita merujuk kepada ruang kod kod penstabil kita maksudkan Subruang
ruang keadaan N Qubit yang merangkumi setiap Vektor yang secara serentak merupakan vektor eigen tambah satu setiap satu daripada
penjana penstabil ini adalah Subruang ruang keadaan qubit en di mana pengekodan yang sah hidup dan kita akan berkata lebih banyak tentang
Subruang ini semasa pelajaran berlanjutan sekarang jom kita lihat beberapa contoh kod penstabil
inilah contoh yang telah kita bincangkan kod pengulangan 3-bit biasa dan kita juga boleh menyatakan
versi terubah suai kod itu dari pelajaran sebelumnya yang boleh mengesan flip fasa berbanding flip bit sebagai kod penstabil seperti yang ditunjukkan
di sini kali ini penjana penstabil mengukur boleh ukur XX berbanding boleh ukur ZZ jadi ini pada dasarnya adalah
semakan pariti dalam asas tambah tolak berbanding asas standard dalam kedua-dua kes kita boleh
segera lihat bahawa kita mempunyai kod penstabil yang sah kerana penjana penstabil bertukar ganti ini adalah
set penjana minimum dan ruang kod adalah bukan remeh seperti yang kita sudah tahu tetapi kita juga boleh lihat dengan agak jelas bahawa kita
tidak boleh menjana negatif -1 kali identiti dan inilah kod Shore 9 Qubit yang juga merupakan kod penstabil
yang dinyatakan oleh penjana penstabil dalam kes ini kita pada dasarnya mempunyai tiga salinan tiga-bit
kod pengulangan satu untuk setiap tiga blok tiga qubit serta dua penjana penstabil terakhir yang
mengambil bentuk yang mengingatkan kepada circuit yang kita lihat dalam pelajaran sebelumnya untuk mengesan flip fasa untuk
kod ini satu lagi cara memikirkan dua penjana penstabil terakhir ini ialah ia mengambil tepat bentuk yang sama seperti yang kita
ada untuk kod pengulangan tiga-bit untuk flip fasa kecuali bahawa kita gantikan XXX untuk x dan sebabnya
ialah bahawa XXX sepadan dengan operasi X pada Qubit Logik yang dikodkan menggunakan kod pengulangan 3-bit tetapi
itu adalah catatan tambahan dan tidak ada yang perlu dibimbangkan sekarang sekiranya tidak jelas seterusnya kita akan lihat beberapa lagi
contoh tetapi sebelum itu izinkan saya sebutkan bahawa orang sering meninggalkan simbol hasil darab tensor apabila menerangkan kod penstabil kerana ia cenderung untuk
memudahkan pembacaannya jadi inilah rupa kod-kod ini tanpa simbol hasil darab tensor
tetapi sudah tentu ini adalah hasil darab tensor dan bukan produk matriks biasa contohnya kita hanya meninggalkan simbol hasil darab tensor supaya ia kurang
berselerak dan corak lebih jelas inilah contoh lain ia dipanggil
kod steam 7 Qubit dan ia mempunyai beberapa ciri yang agak luar biasa kita akan kembali kepada yang satu ini
dari masa ke masa sepanjang pelajaran unit yang tinggal tetapi buat masa ini kita boleh dengan mudah mengesahkan bahawa ia adalah kod penstabil yang sah
khususnya tiga penjana penstabil pertama jelas bertukar ganti dengan satu sama lain kerana Z bertukar ganti dengan
WEBVTT
dirinya sendiri dan identiti bertukar ganti dengan semua perkara dan situasinya adalah serupa untuk tiga yang terakhir jadi ia masih perlu
diperiksa bahawa kalau kita mengambil satu penjana penstabil Z dan satu penjana penstabil X maka ia bertukar ganti
dan adalah mudah untuk melalui sembilan perkadaran yang mungkin untuk menyemak bahawa dalam semua kes ini kita akan sentiasa
mempunyai X dan Z yang sepadan pada kedudukan yang sama bilangan kali genap jadi dua penjana akan bertukar ganti seperti
xx dan ZZ bertukar ganti ia adalah set penjana minimum dan ia mempunyai ruang kod bukan remeh tetapi
saya tidak akan cuba menghujahkan itu dalam video ini dan sebaliknya saya akan tinggalkan itu untuk korang fikir kalau korang mahu kod steam 7 Qubit adalah serupa
dengan kod Shore 9 Qubit dalam erti kata bahawa ia mengekodkan satu Qubit dan membolehkan pembetulan ralat sewenang-wenang pada satu qubit tetapi ia hanya
memerlukan tujuh qubit berbanding sembilan itu bukan bilangan qubit paling sedikit yang diperlukan untuk kod pembetulan ralat bagi
mengekodkan qubit dan membetulkan ralat sewenang-wenang pada satu Qubit berikut ialah kod penstabil yang
biasanya dipanggil kod lima Qubit yang juga mengekodkan satu Qubit dan boleh membetulkan ralat sewenang-wenang satu Qubit
dan lima adalah bilangan qubit terkecil yang memungkinkan ini inilah contoh lain
kod penstabil walaupun ia sebenarnya bukan kod secara berbicara dalam erti kata bahawa ruang kod adalah
satu dimensi khususnya ruang kod untuk kod ini adalah ruang yang dibentangkan oleh ebit atau dengan kata lain keadaan
Bell lima tambah jadi korang sebenarnya tidak boleh mengekodkan mana-mana qubit menggunakan kod ini tetapi ia masih merupakan kod penstabil yang sah di mana ruang
kod kebetulannya adalah satu dimensi dan adalah mungkin untuk melakukan sesuatu yang serupa untuk keadaan GHz
jadi itulah beberapa contoh kod penstabil dan kita akan lihat contoh-contoh yang tidak terhingga banyaknya lagi dalam
pelajaran seterusnya andaikan kita diberi kod penstabil soalan semula jadi untuk ditanya tentangnya
mungkin soalan pertama yang terlintas di fikiran ialah berapa banyak qubit yang dikodkan soalan itu mempunyai jawapan yang sangat mudah
dan untuk menerangkannya jom kita tepat tentang kod penstabil yang dipertimbangkan kita mempunyai R dan Qubit
penjana penstabil P1 hingga p r yang memenuhi tiga keperluan yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya iaitu
penjana penstabil semua bertukar ganti dengan satu sama lain ini adalah set penjana minimum jadi kita tidak akan mendapat
penstabil yang sama kalau kita membuang salah satu penjana dan ada sekurang-kurangnya satu Vektor bukan sifar dalam ruang
kod seperti yang ditunjukkan oleh teorem pada skrin ia mesti kemudiannya bahawa ruang kod kod penstabil mempunyai
Dimensi 2 ^ n tolak r atau satu lagi cara mengatakannya ialah kita boleh mengekodkan n
tolak r qubit menggunakan kod ini jadi secara intuitif kita mempunyai n qubit dalam pengekodan kita dan setiap
penjana penstabil secara berkesan mengambil qubit dari segi berapa banyak qubit yang boleh kita kodkan
teorem ini tidak terlalu sukar untuk dibuktikan dan saya akan tunjukkan korang bukti dalam sebentar lagi tetapi pertama kita akan lihat hanya beberapa
contoh bermula dengan kod pengulangan 3-bit biasa kita mempunyai tiga qubit dalam
pengekodan kita jadi n adalah sama dengan tiga dan ada R sama 2 penjana penstabil dan jadi kita boleh mengekodkan satu
qubit menggunakan kod ini perhatikan bahawa ini bukan tentang ralat mana atau berapa banyak yang boleh dikesan atau
dibetulkan itu adalah hal yang berbeza ini hanyalah pernyataan tentang dimensi ruang kod
sebagai contoh lain pertimbangkan kod 5 Qubit di sini kita mempunyai lima qubit dan empat
penjana penstabil jadi sekali lagi ruang kod mempunyai Dimensi dua yang bermaksud kita boleh mengekodkan satu qubit menggunakan kod ini
dan satu lagi contoh buat masa ini untuk kod penstabil ebit kita mempunyai dua qubit dan dua penjana penstabil jadi
ruang kod adalah satu dimensi dan seperti yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya ia adalah ruang yang dibentangkan oleh keadaan Bell Lima Tambah
kita akan lihat lebih banyak contoh semasa kita teruskan termasuk kod di mana kita boleh mengekodkan lebih daripada satu qubit tetapi buat masa ini jom kita
lihat cara kita boleh membuktikan teorem perkara pertama yang perlu kita perhatikan ialah kerana penstabil
penjana bertukar ganti dan membentuk set penjana minimum dan kerana setiap operasi Pauli adalah songsangnya sendiri setiap
elemen dalam penstabil boleh dinyatakan dengan cara yang unik sebagai produk di mana kita menaikkan setiap penjana penstabil
PK kepada kuasa AK di mana setiap AK adalah sama ada Z atau satu dan kemudian kita darabkan hasilnya
bersama satu lagi cara untuk mengatakannya ialah kita mendapat setiap elemen penstabil dengan mendarabkan bersama beberapa subset daripada
penjana penstabil dan kita tidak pernah mendapatkan elemen penstabil yang sama daripada subset yang berbeza dan satu perkara yang
ini membayangkan ialah satu-satunya cara untuk menyatakan operasi identiti N Qubit dengan cara ini adalah untuk mengambil semua kuasa menjadi
sifar seterusnya jom kita takrifkan pi K sebagai unjuran ke atas ruang eigen tambah satu PK untuk setiap K dari 1 ke R dan ada
formula mudah untuk unjuran ini kita boleh hanya purata PK dengan identiti pada N qubit yang secara berkesan meninggalkan
nilai IG tambah satu sahaja dan mengalihkan semua nilai IG tolak satu ke I
nilai sifar sekarang ruang kod ditakrifkan sebagai set semua vektor yang secara serentak merupakan vektor I tambah satu semua
penjana penstabil memandangkan penjana penstabil bertukar ganti unjuran juga mesti bertukar ganti dan itu
membayangkan bahawa produk unjuran ini juga merupakan unjuran dan khususnya ia adalah unjuran ke atas
persimpangan subruang yang unjuran individu unjur ke atas atau dengan kata lain ia adalah unjuran ke atas
ruang kod kita boleh kembangkan produk ini dan apa yang kita dapat ialah purata ke atas setiap
elemen penstabil dan akhirnya kerana dimensi mana-mana Subruang adalah sama dengan
surih unjuran ke atas Subruang itu kita dapati bahawa dimensi ruang kod adalah purata surih ke atas elemen
penstabil tetapi dengan pengecualian operasi identiti qubit semua elemen penstabil mesti mempunyai
Surih sama dengan sifar kerana tiga matriks polimerasi bukan identiti semua mempunyai Surih sama dengan sifar surih operasi identiti N Qubit
adalah 2 kepada n dan jadi kita dapati bahawa dimensi ruang kod adalah 2 kepada n tolak r yang membuktikan
teorem seterusnya saya akan berkata hanya sedikit tentang cara qubit boleh dikodkan menggunakan kod penstabil tetapi untuk melakukan itu kita pertama
perlu memperkenalkan operasi Clifford operasi Clifford adalah operasi unitari pada mana-mana bilangan
qubit yang boleh dilaksanakan oleh circuit Kuantum dengan set gate yang terhad iaitu gate Hadamard gate S
dan gate knot terkawal perhatikan bahawa gate t tidak disertakan begitu juga gate tofly atau fredin
dan bukan sahaja gate tersebut tidak disertakan dalam senarai ini tetapi sebenarnya ia tidak mungkin untuk melaksanakan gate tersebut
WEBVTT
menggunakan yang disenaraikan di sini jadi ia bukan operasi Clifford operasi Pauli sebaliknya
adalah operasi Clifford dan khususnya ia boleh dilaksanakan menggunakan urutan gate Hadamard dan Es
jadi itulah cara mudah untuk menakrifkan operasi Clifford tetapi ia tidak benar-benar menerangkan mengapa ia ditakrifkan dalam
cara ini atau apa yang istimewa tentang koleksi gate tertentu ini inilah sebab sebenar operasi Clifford ditakrifkan seperti
ini sehingga fasa global operasi Clifford n qubit adalah tepat operasi unitari
yang sentiasa mengubah operasi Pauli kepada operasi Pauli melalui konjugasi untuk lebih tepat operasi unitari nbit
U adalah operasi Clifford sehingga faktor fasa global jika dan hanya jika untuk setiap operasi Pauli qubit n
mengkonjugasikan operasi Pauli itu oleh U memberi kita tambah atau tolak satu kali beberapa operasi n
Qubit Pauli yang mungkin berbeza korang boleh mudah menyemak bahawa sifat ini adalah benar untuk gate Hadamard gate S
dan gate c not jadi ia semestinya berlaku untuk circuit yang dibina daripada gate ini apa yang lebih sukar untuk dibuktikan ialah ia
pergi ke arah yang lain iaitu jika kita diberi operasi unitari nbit U tertentu yang memenuhi sifat ini
maka ia mesti mungkin untuk melaksanakannya sehingga fasa global menggunakan hanya Hadamard s dan cot
gate saya tidak akan melalui bukti implikasi itu tetapi ia benar dan korang boleh mencarinya kalau korang
berminat operasi Clifford bukan Universal untuk pengkomputeran Kuantum bermaksud bahawa kita tidak boleh menjalankan
pengiraan Kuantum sewenang-wenang menggunakan hanya gate Hadamard s dan cot sebenarnya untuk nilai n yang diberikan hanya ada berhingga
n operasi Clifford Qubit jadi ia adalah set operasi yang diskret jadi tidak seperti
set universal gate kuantum kita tidak boleh menganggar operasi unitari sewenang-wenang kepada tahap ketepatan yang diingini dan
sebenarnya melakukan operasi Clifford pada keadaan asas standard diikuti dengan pengukuran asas standard tidak boleh
membolehkan kita melakukan pengiraan yang berada di luar jangkauan algoritma klasik kerana kita boleh mensimulasikan pengiraan bentuk ini dengan cekap
secara klasik fakta ini dikenali sebagai teorem goisman Kil dan bukti standard teorem itu adalah dalam erti kata tertentu
berdasarkan formalisme penstabil khususnya cara ia berfungsi ialah kita boleh menjejaki cara operasi Clifford mengubah operasi Pauli
melalui konjugasi yang boleh dilakukan dengan cekap dan kemudian membuat kesimpulan dari itu apa yang pengiraan lakukan kepada
qubit jadi apakah kaitan ini dengan kod penstabil baik kod penstabil memberikan kita
ruang kod dengan Dimensi tertentu dan kita bebas untuk menggunakan ruang kod itu sesuka hati kita jadi tidak ada yang memaksa kita untuk mengekodkan
qubit ke dalam ruang itu dengan cara yang khusus tetapi ia akan sentiasa mungkin untuk membentuk pengekodan menggunakan operasi Clifford
sebagai pengekod itu bagus kerana operasi Clifford adalah agak mudah berbanding operasi unitari sewenang-wenang
ada cara untuk mengoptimumkan pelaksanaannya yang berfungsi sepanjang garisan yang serupa dengan bukti teorem gsman
canil dan akibatnya circuit untuk melaksanakannya tidak perlu menjadi terlalu
besar khususnya kita sentiasa boleh melakukan pengekodan menggunakan operasi Clifford yang memerlukan sedikit kurang daripada bilangan gate kuadratik
kerana itu sebenarnya benar untuk setiap operasi Clifford jadi ringkasnya untuk kod penstabil yang diberikan ia sentiasa
mungkin untuk mengekodkan qubit dengan cekap menggunakan kod tersebut dan alat matematik yang berguna untuk memahami operasi Clifford boleh membantu dengan proses ini
contohnya inilah pengekod untuk kod steam 7 Qubit ia adalah operasi Clifford dan rupanya
yang ini tidak memerlukan gate S untuk kod penstabil umum pengesanan ralat berfungsi dalam cara berikut
seperti sebelumnya kita akan mengandaikan bahawa kita mempunyai penjana penstabil qubit n P1 hingga p r dan kita akan biarkan e menjadi operasi Pauli N Qubit
yang mewakili ralat hipotetikal pada pengekodan kita hanya mempertimbangkan operasi Pauli
sebagai Ralat by the way kerana pendigitalan Ralat berfungsi dengan cara yang sama untuk kod penstabil sewenang-wenang seperti yang dilakukan untuk kod Shore 9 Qubit
cara kita menyemak ralat ialah mengukur setiap penjana penstabil sebagai
boleh ukur ada R penjana penstabil jadi ini bermaksud hasil R di mana setiap satu adalah tambah satu atau tolak satu
atau nilai binari kalau korang suka mengaitkan sifar dengan tambah satu dan satu dengan tolak satu dan hasil R ini
bersama-sama membentuk sindrom sama seperti yang kita ada untuk kod pengulangan tiga-bit apabila R adalah sama dengan
dua secara umum ada tiga kemungkinan kes untuk ralat e dari segi pengesanannya dan ia adalah seperti berikut pertama
boleh jadi e berada dalam penstabil bermaksud bahawa adalah mungkin untuk menjana E daripada penjana penstabil atau
secara lebih umum boleh jadi e bersamaan dengan elemen penstabil sehingga fasa global
dalam kes ini e sebenarnya bukan ralat sama sekali kerana ia tidak mempunyai kesan dalam ruang kod selain daripada mungkin
menyuntikkan fasa global yang tidak mempunyai sebarang kesan jadi kita tidak perlu membimbangkan sama sekali tentang ralat seperti ini apa jua
tindakan bukan remeh yang mungkin dimilikinya berlaku di luar ruang kod jadi ia tidak membimbangkan
kita jauh lebih membimbangkan ialah kemungkinan e tidak berada dalam penstabil walaupun sehingga fasa global tetapi
namun ia bertukar ganti dengan setiap satu penjana penstabil kita ingat bahawa ia adalah
anti-pertukaran ganti ralat dengan penjana penstabil yang menyebabkan tolak satu muncul di suatu tempat dalam sindrom
tetapi itu tidak berlaku dalam kes ini jadi ini adalah ralat yang sebenarnya mengubah vektor dalam ruang kod dengan cara yang
bukan remeh dan kita tahu ini kerana selainnya ia akan berkadar dengan elemen penstabil tetapi ia pergi
tidak dikesan oleh kod jadi ini adalah kes yang buruk kita mempunyai ralat yang mungkin mengubah
apa jua maklumat Kuantum yang telah kita kodkan tetapi kod tidak menyedari fakta ini contohnya untuk tiga-bit
kod pengulangan XXX termasuk dalam kategori ini dan kemungkinan terakhir ialah a e
anti-tukar ganti dengan sekurang-kurangnya satu daripada penjana penstabil dan ini bermaksud bahawa kod mengesan ralat ini kerana
kita akan mendapat sindrom dengan sekurang-kurangnya satu tolak satu di suatu tempat dalamnya yang menunjukkan bahawa ada sesuatu yang salah dan kita perlu cuba membetulkan ralat ini
entah bagaimana jadi itulah kemungkinannya sebagai titik terminologi
apabila kita merujuk kepada jarak kod penstabil apa yang kita maksudkan ialah berat minimum operasi Pauli termasuk dalam
kategori kedua bermaksud ia mengubah ruang kod dengan cara yang bukan remeh tetapi kod tidak
mengesan ini dan apabila kita katakan bahawa kod penstabil adalah kod penstabil nmd menggunakan
kurungan segi empat berganda seperti yang ditunjukkan pada skrin apa yang dimaksudkan ialah pengekodan adalah n qubit panjangnya
WEBVTT
kod mampu mengekodkan M qubit jadi ruang kod mempunyai Dimensi 2 m dan jaraknya adalah D jadi ralat mesti mempunyai
berat D atau lebih untuk mengubah keadaan logik mana-mana Qubit yang telah kita kodkan tanpa dikesan sebagai
ralat kita sekarang akan lihat kod steam 7 Qubit sebagai contoh dan kita akan tentukan apakah jaraknya
inilah penjana penstabil untuk kod ini dan ingat bahawa jarak adalah berat minimum
operasi Pauli qubit n yang bertukar ganti dengan semua penjana penstabil tetapi ia sendiri tidak berada dalam penstabil begitu juga
ia berkadar dengan elemen penstabil apa yang akan kita tentukan ialah kod ini mempunyai jarak
tiga cara kita akan menentukan ini ialah untuk pertama mempertimbangkan mana-mana operasi Pauli yang mempunyai berat paling banyak dua dan kita akan
menyimpulkan bahawa satu-satunya cara ia boleh mengira dengan semua enam penjana penstabil adalah untuk menjadi identiti yang sentiasa merupakan elemen
penstabil jadi jom kita andaikan bahawa matriks Pauli yang mungkin bukan identiti yang membentuk operasi ini yang akan kita
panggil P dan Q muncul dalam dua kedudukan paling kiri ini hanyalah satu kes dan kita memang perlu
mempertimbangkan semua lokasi lain yang mungkin untuk matriks Pauli yang mungkin bukan identiti ini tetapi hujahnya pada dasarnya sama untuk semua
kemungkinan lokasi baik dengan andaian operasi ini bertukar ganti dengan semua enam
penjana penstabil jadi khususnya ia bertukar ganti dengan yang ini dan ia juga bertukar ganti dengan yang ini
Q sejajar dengan matriks identiti dalam kedua-dua penjana ini itulah sebabnya kita memilih kedua-dua ini dan kita mempunyai matriks identiti
dalam lima kedudukan paling kanan ralat ini dan jadi kita simpulkan bahawa P mesti bertukar ganti dengan kedua-dua x
dan z kerana selainnya ralat ini akan anti-tukar ganti dengan salah satu daripada dua penjana ini tetapi satu-satunya matriks Pauli yang
bertukar ganti dengan kedua-dua x dan z adalah identiti jadi P mesti adalah identiti dan sekarang kita tahu itu kita
boleh memilih dua lagi penjana penstabil yang mempunyai X dan z dalam kedudukan kedua dari kiri dan kita boleh
membuat kesimpulan yang serupa tentang Q jadi tidak ada cara untuk ralat berat paling banyak 2 untuk pergi tidak dikesan oleh kod ini
melainkan ia hanya operasi identiti yang berada dalam penstabil jadi ini sebenarnya bukan
ralat sebaliknya ada operasi Pauli berat tiga yang bertukar ganti dengan semua enam penjana penstabil ini
tetapi tidak berkadar dengan elemen penstabil dan inilah dua contoh jadi kita telah menyimpulkan bahawa
kod ini mempunyai jarak tiga perkara terakhir yang akan kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran ini ialah membetulkan ralat untuk
kod penstabil seperti biasa kita akan mengandaikan kod kita dinyatakan oleh penjana penstabil nbit
P1 hingga p dan jom kita mulakan dengan memikirkan sedikit tentang semua kemungkinan ralat yang boleh
berlaku ada dua kepada r kemungkinan sindrom dan seperti yang saya sebut sebelumnya dalam pelajaran sindrom ini mengasingkan semua
kemungkinan operasi Pauli qubit en kepada koleksi saiz sama jadi itu bermaksud 4 kepada N / 2 kepada r operasi Pauli
dalam setiap set jadi apabila kita melihat sindrom tertentu boleh jadi mana-mana satu daripada empat kepada N dibahagi 2
kepada r ralat ini adalah bertanggungjawab kita memang mengira berlebihan sedikit di sini walaupun kerana beberapa daripada ralat ini
mempunyai kesan yang sama tepat pada ruang kod khususnya kalau kita mempunyai ralat E dan kita darab e Dengan Mana-mana
elemen penstabil s maka kita akan mendapat ralat lain yang mempunyai kesan yang sama tepat dalam ruang kod sebagai e jadi
ini adalah ralat yang setara penstabil mempunyai dua kepada r elemen dan kalau kita mengambil kira ini maka kita dapati
bahawa untuk setiap sindrom ada empat kepada N tolak r kelas setara ralat yang mungkin menyebabkan satu
sindrom itu dan apa yang dimaksudkan ialah melainkan R sama dengan n dalam kes ini kita mempunyai ruang kod satu dimensi dan
oleh itu tidak boleh mengekodkan mana-mana qubit sama sekali tidak akan mungkin untuk membetulkan setiap ralat yang boleh kita kesan sebaliknya
apa yang perlu kita lakukan ialah memilih hanya satu operasi pembetulan untuk setiap sindrom dengan harapan untuk membetulkan hanya satu kelas ralat yang setara
jadi bagaimana kita harus memilih pembetulan yang perlu dilakukan untuk setiap sindrom strategi semula jadi ialah memilih
operasi Pauli berat paling rendah yang menyebabkan apa jua sindrom yang kita ukur dengan idea bahawa operasi Pauli berat lebih rendah
mewakili penjelasan yang lebih mungkin untuk sindrom itu ini mungkin sebenarnya bukan
kes untuk beberapa model kebisingan dan satu lagi strategi semula jadi ialah entah bagaimana mengira ralat yang paling mungkin yang menyebabkan
sindrom yang diberikan tetapi buat masa ini kita hanya akan mempertimbangkan strategi di mana kita cuba membetulkan ralat dengan memilih operasi Pauli berat paling rendah yang menyebabkan
sindrom untuk kod penstabil jarak D strategi ini akan sentiasa membolehkan kita membetulkan ralat yang mempunyai berat secara ketat
kurang daripada separuh D atau dengan kata lain berat paling banyak D tolak 1 atas 2 dan saya akan terangkan secara ringkas mengapa ini
berlaku ini akan menunjukkan contohnya bahawa kod steam 7 Qubit boleh membetulkan mana-mana ralat Pauli berat satu dan oleh
pendigitalan ralat ini bermaksud bahawa sama seperti kod Shore 9 Qubit kod steam boleh membetulkan untuk
ralat sewenang-wenang pada satu qubit jadi inilah cara ini berfungsi pertimbangkan bahawa bulatan ini mewakili semua kemungkinan operasi Pauli
yang menghasilkan sindrom semua tambah 1 yang merupakan sindrom yang mencadangkan bahawa tiada ralat berlaku
dan tidak ada yang salah antara operasi ini kita mempunyai elemen penstabil atau benar-benar
operasi yang berkadar dengan elemen penstabil dan kita juga mempunyai ralat bukan remeh yang mengubah ruang kod entah bagaimana tetapi ia tidak
dikesan oleh kod dan Kita Tahu mengikut definisi jarak bahawa setiap operasi Pauli dalam kategori ini mesti mempunyai berat sekurang-kurangnya
D kerana D ditakrifkan sebagai berat minimum operasi ini kita juga mempunyai operasi Pauli
yang menyebabkan sindrom lain muncul dan kita boleh mempertimbangkan setiap sindrom secara bergilir kalau kita mahu tetapi di sini kita hanya bayangkan
bahawa satu sindrom s tersebut telah muncul sekarang bayangkan bahawa e adalah ralat dalam kategori ini
yang mempunyai berat secara ketat kurang daripada separuh jarak D baik kita tidak tahu bahawa ini adalah
semestinya operasi Pauli berat minimum dalam bulatan ini jadi jom kita ambil C sebagai operasi berat minimum dalam set ini atau salah satunya sekiranya ada
seri jadi boleh jadi c sama dengan e atau mungkin tidak tetapi kerana C mempunyai
berat minimum kita tahu bahawa ia tidak mungkin mempunyai berat lebih besar daripada berat E kerana C juga berada dalam set
dan ia mempunyai berat minimum jadi operasi pembetulan C mesti mempunyai berat secara ketat kurang daripada separuh
D jadi apa yang berlaku kalau kita guna pembetulan C ini kepada apa jua keadaan kita setelah ralat e
berlaku jawapannya ialah keadaan yang kita peroleh adalah C * e didarabkan dengan pengekodan asal kerana kita pertama
darab dengan E itu adalah ralat dan kemudian kita darab dengan C untuk cuba membetulkannya dan produk ini mesti berada dalam
WEBVTT
penstabil atau berkadar dengan elemen penstabil dan inilah sebabnya pertama kerana e dan C memberi kita
sindrom yang sama C * e mesti memberi kita sindrom semua tambah satu itu kerana untuk
penjana penstabil yang diberikan sama ada c dan e kedua-duanya bertukar ganti dengan penjana itu atau kedua-duanya anti-tukar ganti ia mesti sama untuk
kedua-duanya kerana sindromnya adalah sama dan kalau korang fikirkan sebentar ia membayangkan bahawa c * e mesti
bertukar ganti dengan semua penjana penstabil dan akhirnya C * e mesti berada
dalam penstabil kerana beratnya tidak boleh lebih besar daripada jumlah berat c dan e dan jadi beratnya
adalah secara ketat kurang daripada D dan ini bermaksud bahawa kita berjaya membetulkan e kerana menggunakan e diikuti dengan C tidak melakukan apa-apa kepada
ruang kod jadi itu bagus tetapi ada satu masalah sahaja dan itu ialah untuk kod penstabil
secara umum ia adalah masalah yang sukar secara pengiraan untuk mengira operasi berat paling rendah yang menyebabkan sindrom yang diberikan
dan memang itu benar walaupun untuk kod klasik yang dalam konteks ini kita boleh fikirkan sebagai kod penstabil
di mana kita hanya mempunyai matriks identiti dan matriks Pauli z yang muncul sebagai faktor tensor dalam penjana penstabil
jadi tidak seperti langkah pengekodan operasi Clifford tidak datang untuk menyelamatkan kita kali ini dan satu-satunya penyelesaian yang munasabah
ialah untuk memilih kod tertentu yang mana pembetulan yang baik boleh dikira dengan cekap dan tidak ada resipi untuk
ini mudahnya mereka bentuk kod penstabil seperti ini adalah sebahagian daripada keseniaan
reka bentuk Kod Kuantum dan itulah tempat yang baik untuk berhenti untuk pelajaran ini saya harap korang akan sertai saya
untuk pelajaran seterusnya di mana kita akan lihat beberapa konstruksi Kod Kuantum tertentu termasuk kod yang menggambarkan keseniaan reka bentuk Kod Kuantum
dengan cara yang agak menakjubkan selamat tinggal buat masa ini